the beautiful sounds of the city hi guys
I'm grace Helbig you know that I guess
unless you don't welcome to a new video
welcome to Fright Night right there is a
look back at my week in blog form so
let's look back at some of the things
that have happened in my world this week
things are different the hair is changed
courtesy when DJ Diaz hooray
and you raise might think that this is
an easy process going from long to short
but no let's see it we got a bunch of
stuff over here we got all windy stuff
over here I got this station perfectly
next aisle the 9th right there this
thing is there this thing's been there
it's a whole process but yeah short hair
morning guys happy Tuesday we're at the
Grove right now and we're gonna shoot an
interview for enews on the trolley yeah
so exciting let's do it yeah this is
something that's happening today alleys
here we're all here Party Time excellent
I'm getting fitted to become a hermit
crab this is not a joke this is not a
test
look that's happening and this is
happening a little bit mix s it all
makes sense
video
yeah he's gonna get over here he's
responsible for its makeover that's
happening right now
a very tough super-awesome project
that's going down what actually are you
I am uh I'm a hermit crab that lives at
the bottom but I will forget about you
that's what you are yeah it's basically
a Newark leave my spirit animal I love
the club
I love the thumbs-up club so I reckon
you could crush accounting that or a
coconut yeah or maybe you know lights
just a cotton ball yeah mister you guys
know I'm not the only person involved in
this mamrie Hart has a character that
she will be playing and it's Pam look at
that that's so crazy also produces
director Jack Barry from not too deep is
involved in this and I look that's very
very hard
[Music]
made it to Chicago look at this cute
little room so cute
I feel like this is very Hannah Hart and
look at this view
can you see that it's what is that oh
it's an outside the mamrie just went to
do a book signing and I have to do a
life signing I have to get my life
put it back on track and then we're
gonna do a meeting for the show tomorrow
yeah yeah this is a pool you see that I
could spot people into bathing suits one
of my least favorite hobbies time for a
good old fashioned stress run okay I
just walked a wall greet and see too
much [ __ ] for myself in the show this is
literally the cutest neighborhood ever
oh just a second City improv huge a
famous and wonderful and a beautiful bar
across the street and then two flower
shops Chicago
damn it literally in just a few minutes
good morning guys it is Friday no it is
not
it is Thursday it's Thursday and it's
show day and
I have to say this so far this mamrie
Hart leg of a no filter show tour has
been the healthiest yet I literally went
with Hannah and just bought some juices
last night while we rehearsing we put on
some green tea masks who know that this
would be mamrie Hart author of you
deserve a drinks book tour we'll see how
long it lasts but tonight's our first
show at the Vic in Chicago and I'm so
excited so we're doing our classic
last-minute scramble so don't I mean
I've just become a European tennis pro
what are these kids doing look is
walking around all right yep there you
go today this is over there to the right
in the park I've never heard a more
board made to the Vic and Hannah and I
are backstage signing posters this one
left for cellphone in that crazy cab
yeah but I filmed on the way over so
luckily that man is bringing it back to
us hooray
reckless optimism yeah also he was
wearing winter gloves eating carrots and
saying the words
faster faster over and over again to
himself
we
Bob and raising cute
arrived alive
[Music]
hi Shaco it is Thursday night we just
finished the first nofilter show up for
me rights book tour and it went
uber well um yeah that's all I wanted to
say so I wake up we all wake up in like
four hours and got on a flight to go to
New York and do another show yeah and
then before the other show hand I may
murder literally like a billion other
things so god bless thanks for a great
first show Chicago good morning it is
four or five hours later and we are at
the airport yeah let's go to New York
memories bag weight fifty pounds what a
day
[Music]
a sweaty New Yorker my room wasn't ready
so I went and did some errands really
important errands um
Zara Sephora and I got some chips but I
finally got my room and look whoa cool
it's a full-size refrigerator fancy born
of the silver spoon NYU student hipster
dorm hotel room now we have like an hour
a little over an hour before to go to
the theater for the New York show
tonight so I want to try and edit this
video right now and also cleanse my
person so okay there you go that was the
end of that I hope you enjoyed it if you
liked this video give it a thumbs up if
you want to leave a comment about
something do that down to there and
don't breathe subscribe so that you
don't have to look for these videos they
look for you I don't know
[Music]
we should totally do videos and Michelle